let's move on with our science critic
okay this is what he had to say
specifically about energy
what is energy is energy a thing
and if it's not
can a thing contain
energy you know like uh you contain a
water in a bucket or something like that
is that what energy is something that
you can hold and contain that's going to
be the issue okay this is what he had to
say and this is what is at stake okay
yeah yeah planar walk whatever his name
is um i'm gonna be addressing issue by
issue that he raised he raised so many
issues and it's uh really um
uh it was in line with what i was going
to talk about in science so
i'm going to
essentially answer his questions and by
answering his questions his uh the
issues that he raised i think i'm going
to be enlightening people on what the
scientific method really is and where
the current scientific method taught in
schools
is uh is irrational it doesn't conduce
to the questions that people ask people
want to know how gravity works people
want to know how magnetism works and
these people are giving us equations and
irrational explanations
after 400 years of the so-called you
know 17th century scientific revolution
in which they changed the greek
scientific method and they said uh no
we're going to be doing math in other
words measurements and equations and
we're going to do experiments
and it turns out with all that we ended
up with irrational explanations in
physics in so-called mathematical
physics in the establishment so that's
what we're criticizing and we're saying
that math that uh mathematical method as
we call it uh or mathematical method has
uh no validity whatsoever it doesn't
answer the questions we're seeking okay
so here let's uh run with the science
critic let's see what he had to say
the questions and issues addressed in
this rebuttal include
is energy a thing
if not does it make sense in physics to
say that an object can contain energy
energy is not just capacity energy is
the capacity to do work because a lot of
things do have the capacity to do work
that would make them contain energy now
i don't think i've ever heard anyone
define energy as a substance i've
usually heard it in reference to being
contained by something
the issue is whether energy is a
physical object and the question is
whether if it's not a physical object
can something contain energy in other
words if energy is a concept
right
can you contain a concept for the
purposes of physics
this is what uh what i'm gonna raise
against this uh issue that these people
raise energy uh is defined as the
capacity and in fact this gentleman
defined it as the capacity okay blah
blah blah blah blah we don't care what
comes after the word capacity because
it's irrelevant capacity is what energy
is defined as and capacity is a concept
okay so this is the issue capacity is
not a physical object in other words
it's not a thing it's not a substance
it's not a something okay capacity the
maximum amount in other words capacity
is defined as an amount
okay
capacity is a concept any and that's
what energy is a concept okay so energy
is not a physical standalone object you
can't draw a picture of energy you
cannot make a you cannot take a snapshot
of energy you cannot show me in a
picture
what energy is all what's
when you say what is this what is that
what is a table what is a tree you
should be able to draw it that's the
answer to a what question you can't say
what is love not in science not in
physics
because love is not a what
okay you can define the word love but
you can't say what is love
that's the issue okay and that's when we
confuse ordinary speech with scientific
language especially the language of
physics physics the nouns have to be
physical objects things
that which has shape not that which you
can define right
okay so uh here we have um
a synthesis of the problem in physics
contain
is a physical word when you say that you
contain something you cannot contain a
concept you cannot say the the the brain
contains the mind
for example mind is a concept you can't
say brain contains mind okay you can say
my brain contains cells uh you know
anything you want something that is
physical okay contains atoms okay
molecules but you can't say it contains
mind
and uh and here's an example you can say
um in ordinary speech you can say i have
a headache
okay headache is a concept not a
physical object you can't draw a picture
of a headache you can't hold it in your
hands okay
uh you can have a dying like a dime in
your pocket okay so there's a difference
between having a headache and having a
dying having a concept and having an
object okay you can say that you can
contain water which is a thing you
cannot say that you can contain love or
intelligence that the you know the brain
contains intelligence you can't say
something like that in physics for the
purposes of physics okay
so if energy is not a thing then energy
cannot be contained
and this is where the problem really uh
comes in here okay this fellow is saying
energy is equal to capacity this is a
reasoning his line of reasoning okay he
says energy is the capacity okay
okay and so he said things have the
capacity he uses the word have the verb
have
which he takes from ordinary speech he
doesn't realize that he's introducing
a uh language of ordinary speech
suddenly into physics he's saying things
have the capacity okay
this is an irrational statement in
physics okay so you so then he since he
equated energy with capacity he says
things have in other words contain
energy suddenly he's now containing a
concept called energy okay
and he
reinforces that by saying energy is
contained by things but it's irrational
physics to have a concept to contain a
concept this is where he made his error
okay and this is the same here the
establishment makes and everybody out
there makes because they introduce
language of ordinary speech using have
and contain
touch see and they're talking about
concepts okay
and uh so this is this is this is where
the problem is okay so keep that in mind
whenever you use language here we we are
correcting
the language of physics and we hope that
people do not confuse okay
ordinary speech with scientific language